[Musik]
pakistans müssten die container seien
oder hier hergestellt oder haha ich bin
ja ich bin doch lieb und zusammen sind
wir risiken ein youtube kanal der sich
seit dreieinhalb jahren vor allem mit
dem thema nachhaltige und faire kleidung
beschäftigen weil ich von wem wurden
denn genau hier hergestellt von plan b
das ist ein format vom zdf und die
betreiben konstruktiven journalismus wir
wurden irgendwie nur hier hergestellt
klamotten sollten wir mitbringen keine
ahnung
erst einmal was ich da sehe wie brief
lieber richtig nation heute wird nichts
weggeworfen ihr müsst ihr in einer
upcycling challenge gegeneinander
antreten wenn ich ganz gut weil die
teile nämlich eigentlich auch nicht
gestaltet jeweils aus euren alten
klamotten ein neues cooles teil
unterstützung bekommt ihr von einer
erfahrenen schneiderin bewertet werden
nachhaltigkeit grad der verwandlung
praktischer nutzen style handwerkliches
geschick lasst eurer kreativität freien
lauf da würde ich sagen weil die hast du
gar keine chance das gewicht das denkst
du
jannik könnt ihr mal ein bisschen
schauen dass wir vielleicht zusätzlich
braucht ein bisschen überfordert ich war
noch nie im stoffler haben keine ahnung
was sie alles so gibt es ist natürlich
auch eine challenge machen das heißt ich
bewerte ich habe spaß am zuhören muss
schauen was ihr daraus zaubert und einer
davon ist dann am ende der gewinner sind
es ja schließlich die farbe vielleicht
könnte hier noch ein paar topflappen
man könnte ihnen vielleicht ein bisschen
kleiner machen ein bisschen zu groß ist
auch schon das stimmt schon dass hier
könnte man jetzt abtrennen und da was
drauf nehmen
dann könnte es auch kurzärmelig machen
und ist ein bisschen auf pumpe mit
irgendwelchen logos oder schriften von
dem von hardrock shirts man kann jetzt
schon das ausschneiden an da drauf
machen noch die frage wie gut dass am
ende aus ja aber das ja ich habe schon
gesagt will ich dann helf ich dir dabei
dass es möglichst gut wird jeder zieht
jetzt mal sein teil an vermittelt gucken
wie das so passt wie das sitzt
es ist teil hätte immerhin lieber mal
ein kleidercontainer in wörth ist es ist
oversize ist das in mittlerweile aber
das ist unser wasser ist doch mal die
community ok dann legen wir los
hier sind die maschinen da haben wir
platz zum arbeiten du hast eine schere
du kannst du schon mal deinen kopf
abschneiden die schere nicht mehr so
dass nach unten nicht so manche markt
jetzt leite ich möchte schreien tut
schon ein bisschen weh upcycling heißt
für mich weniger milch produzieren als
vielleicht dadurch entstehen wir dass
man ein komplettes teil einfach
wegschmeißen will es gibt durchaus schon
viele modemarken die upcycling machen
jetzt nicht halt so fertige
kleidungsstücke umgehen oder sowas
sondern der verarbeiten hat die
ressourcen die schon da sind stoffe die
über sind also da ist auf jeden fall
schon einiges da was sie jetzt bestimmt
vor zehn jahren noch nicht sogar am rand
so zögerlich kommt 18
ich glaube ja nicht weiß gar nicht was
er da macht das nichts das unternehmen
hat mit der schere das kann es ja gar
nicht es ist nur mit man sehen
ja also hier der ja liegt er stellt sich
nicht ganz so gut an
ich habe aber auch den schweren par und
habt ihr schon mal gemäht männer
nähmaschine
ich sehe diesen tausende köpfe ja die
brauchen wir aber eindrücke also ich
sags schon hier an der nähmaschine dass
mir das jetzt ganz langsam erklärt gar
nicht das bekommt jetzt ok super damit
ihr durch die wir auch mal auf deine
seite sind da noch die nadel jannik
jetzt ist gedacht da was ist wir den
kanal gegründet haben dass wir jetzt
hier sitzen nur nehmen ich hätte nicht
gedacht dass wir dreieinhalb vier jahre
uns mit dem thema beschäftigen und es
vielleicht immer noch nicht können
dafür übergab es gibt halt in manchen
bereichen eine twitter nennt und
analysen
jetzt gehen wir auch mal ein handwerk
und merken dass es ganz schön viel
arbeit ist und merken das ist eigentlich
auch nicht kann also dass du es nicht
kann es auch kämpfen sollten dadurch
auftrags für jannik wenn man es jetzt
wirklich mal macht dieses handwerk erst
mal bewusst die ganzen mehreren wagen
dadurch zum beispiel die shirts
tagtäglich für uns nehmen wie viel
arbeit das macht wenig lohn dafür
bekommen wir haben einfach das fertige
produkt in der hand habe recyceln
upcycling macht ja auch sinn weil die
ganzen ressourcen brauchen auch energie
sowas haben wir letztens gelesen was
23.000 taschen kilo baumwolle ist
ungefähr dann mit jeans und t shirt als
kontrast hätte die frage die sich der
mainstream markt entwickelt weil es muss
auf jeden fall was geändert werden so
wie es läuft geht halt nicht und die
leute werden ja immer bewusster und
fangen anhalt wieder kleinere labels und
marken zu kaufen mehr geld auszugeben
willst natürlich auch immer teurer und
von daher ist ja immer das eine sache
der nachfrage auch weil die gefällt dir
deinen fortschritt den super also ich
bin begeistert von meinem werk genauso
wie ich es haben wollte also handwerk
ist eigentlich voll mein ding nicht
[Musik]
sommerliebe rivale ich bin soweit durch
muss jetzt nur noch die nabelschnur
durchtrennen
[Musik]
ich muss mich gut
du musst dich ran halten mein lieber
du hast ja recht daran halten ja du bist
du deinen letzten frei bezeichnet seid
ja ich bin auf jeden fall zufrieden mit
meiner arbeit vom design und so weiter
es ist so wie es mir vorgestellt habe
auch wenn ich jetzt die shirts nicht
weiter verarbeitet habe ich kann die
aber trotzdem für die wohnung ja zum
kurzen verweis auf die ärmel gekürt die
weiter gekürzt und maß gekürzt was hast
du gemacht
jetzt bin ich auf jeden fall sehr
gespannt könnt ihr eure teil mal
anziehen ja
ich ja als ich von der frage nicht so
viel verändert die anmelde und jetzt
also ganz gut von der länge oder habt
ihr so vorgestellt und die platzierung
ja auch in deinem sinne
die ist top so und bei dir ja ich bin
der schnitt passt jetzt ganz gut jetzt
hat und findest du sein ist auch so auf
die schnelle am ende dann doch noch mal
ganz gefühl um ja ja ich finde auch als
eigentlich nicht so schlecht mit dem
moped ja gut dann gehen wir jetzt mal zu
bewertungen über nachhaltig warte jetzt
beide aber du kannst noch einen mehr
weil er hat ja hier was neues
der style ich war ja ziemlich abgeneigt
hier von dem beige aber finde ich nach
wie vor auch immer noch scheußlich aber
jetzt hatte hat oder so einen schönen
stock draufgemacht noch ne also du hast
jetzt echt das rausgeholt muss ich sagen
ich gehe jetzt mal noch einen punkt für
das scheußliche in ruhe das heißt du
findest dich scheußlicher als b schneien
schlecht ach so ist das war auch in
grünem höher und du kriegst für den
style dann kommt also der yannick hat
hier die nahe die bündchen und alles und
dann noch hier patch drauf und so
definitiv grüner vom bei punkte sogar
werd ich finde sie damit es muss doch
auch holen jetzt da stehen wir ein paar
ecken über und das soll so sein
vom handwerklichen muss sagen ist er
ehrlich davon
der praktische nutzen ja dass du jetzt
mit deinen teil so zufrieden dass zu den
jetzt auch weiterhin anziehst bis
überlegt mir noch tatsächlich finden
fanden jetzt echt cool als sind gerade
probiert habe mussten aber noch ein
bisschen auf mich wirken lassen
ich kann mir gerade sehr gut vorstellen
denen auch wirklich anzuziehen
klar ist der neue alles irgendwie auch
so vom style aber doch ich bin schon
mein alltag an könnte ein trend werden
ja gehe ich jetzt mal beiden grünen
button
ich muss sagen der grad der verwandlung
ist auf jeden fall hier klar bei yannic
und weiß jetzt gleichstand wer muss ich
leider in den jannik noch einen punkt
geben obwohl er das hässliche wenig hat
weil ich finde so im grunde ja ist es so
im gesamt dingen glaube ich cooler typ
fazit des tages meint trotzdem schöner
ist völlig in ordnung interessiert nicht
aber gerade wirklich nicht die bohne
weil ich hab dann bis zum nächsten mal
so wir hatten auf jeden fall großen spaß
heute oder oli mega mega viel gelernt
haben ja auch noch das haben wir auch
noch schreibt es auch gerne mal in die
kommentare offen ihr solches wetter hier
tragen würde
wir machen auf jeden fall mit dem zdf
bzw plan b noch eine weitere challenge
wir verlinken wo das video viel spaß
beim abdecken bis dahin wir gehen jetzt
im pizzaessen